hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video
that i know is going to make my stomach
turn like i'm not going to like it
at all you know i'm pretty like
i don't know how to put it like
optimistic about people
people are good but this video i think
is gonna change my mind it's titled how
to
cheat in a relationship and woman
running a smv background check it's by
alpha male
strategies this will be interesting
let's see how it goes
okay i'm like nervous to watch this i
like don't want to
what's up fellas so i got a guy who's
married
that wants to know how to [ __ ] these
hoes to sleep
all right and so this can go for you
guys who in relationships or
you dating a woman exclusively or
whatever the case may be all right
so here's the thing with this guys
theoretically i would like for you to
tell the girl that you're
dating a married that you want to have
an open
relationship and y'all know me i'm not
on some moral
ethics do the right thing i don't give a
[ __ ] about that
clearly no this is the issue right here
guys ain't nobody got time for all that
stress and ducking and dodging and
looking over your shoulder and [ __ ] like
that don't nobody have time for that
[ __ ]
all right but let's just hypothetically
say you in a relationship you got
kids and you know the woman gonna
probably be pissed off and want to put
you on child support and alimony so
let's just hypothetically say that's the
situation
and you want to [ __ ] other women all
right you ain't asking me to come over
here and judge you you just asked me to
give you a bite so that's what i'm gonna
do
i do not like this i don't like it at
all
ask me questions i'm not gonna stand on
my soap box and say you should do this
and you should do i'm not your dad all
right you asked me for advice i'm gonna
give it to you all right
so first thing guys if you're in a
relationship or are you married and you
want to [ __ ] other hoes
is you have to tell the other women that
you have a girl at home
you have to [ __ ] do it she has to be
down with the [ __ ] game plan
alright now here's the thing guys
you don't lie to women all right
it is counterproductive i i've said that
[ __ ] over and over again
the other dating coaches they was on the
smear campaign to make it seem like
i was lying i got y'all guys lying to
women
this is all i have ever said about uh
lean women on guys is if you meet a
woman who's looking for a relationship
and she asks you are you open to a
relationship
you tell her yes if the right woman
comes along
and guys for whatever y'all guys have
heard
that is not a lie all right and i'm
gonna tell y'all guys
why that is not alive guys let me tell
you something right now
if you're a 21 year old red pill guy
and you think that you're gonna live for
the next 50 or 60 years of your life
just dating women you got another
[ __ ] thing coming
all right at some point you will meet a
woman
that you would want to settle down with
the thing with us red pill guys is we
don't
look for it but one day a woman will
come in your life
that's right for you and let me tell
y'all guys something so y'all guys just
to put things in the context guys i
don't been got over that little red pill
women gonna dump you when you lose your
job [ __ ] i got all that [ __ ]
a long time ago i i was that was kind of
upset to me but i got over that [ __ ]
about you
dang he just
i would not i like don't you know what
to say this is
not i do not like watching this
no women like reese i've been gathered
with that do y'all guys not know why i
don't
theoretically not open to a relationship
because women get on my [ __ ]
nerves all right i only could take women
in small
doses all right the average woman has
way too much [ __ ] masculine
energy for me i cannot tolerate
i'll have you know i am delightful
delightful
what masculine energy them for too
[ __ ] long they get on
my [ __ ] nerves do i have masculine
energy i like for real
don't know what that means sometimes
because i like work hard and stuff but
i'm pretty
if i take a personality test like it
says i'm pretty agreeable like i'm
pretty go with the flow
but like i do like to like like i've
always taken pride in the fact that i
work hard
all right and so that is why i'm not
open to a relationship that i
love my space all right and that just
goes to show you guys
how much masculine energy women picked
up the last
10 to 15 years because i do not remember
that 15 years ago women having all this
[ __ ] masculine energy all right
i constantly always have to put a woman
in a friend zone or
pull back whatever the case may be get
uh be because these women carry so much
[ __ ] masculine energy
that they're constantly trying to take
the reins in a relationship
well i don't have time for that [ __ ]
i'm all up for [ __ ] tests
and i know women got a [ __ ] test to test
your strength but it gets on my [ __ ]
nerves all right so what
until i meet a real feminine woman that
ain't got a [ __ ] [ __ ] test
every [ __ ] five minutes to get the
power in the relationship
i will stay dating all right and that's
the thing with that and i
listen guys y'all know i pass [ __ ] tests
and the [ __ ] still
[ __ ] test they carry way too much
[ __ ] masculine energy
they constantly are constantly trying to
get the reins in the relationship
that's why okay we get it so he he deals
with a lot
like he could have just said this in one
sentence
i don't date girls because they have too
much masculine energy he's just going on
i'd like to deal with women like i do
that's why i like to just date them
because i don't need that [ __ ]
headache
but one day in this goal for you
brothers too one day you will meet a
feminine woman who is submissive i don't
know when that's gonna be but you will
meet it i'm open to it i just don't look
for it if i ever meet a woman that's
very
feminine and i find very attractive and
she suck a mean dick
and she got her own money i am very open
to a relationship
marriage [ __ ] no all right y'all see the
marriage laws and [ __ ] like that that
ain't happening all right
but a relationship if a woman is
feminine and she don't get on my [ __ ]
nerves for a year
maybe i'll be open to going exclusive
all right so theoretically guys
that is not a lie just to be and even
for you guys even for you red pill guys
that think
that you don't never want to
relationship i'm saying they're telling
you right now
one day if i was to check back on you in
15 20 years
yo as i have two [ __ ] kids and a
[ __ ] marriage i get i
guaran [ __ ] to you all right i guaran
or at the very least
of relationship i guaran [ __ ] to you
all right guys
so that's the bottom [ __ ] thing the
thing with us red pill brothers is
we know our value and so we ain't gonna
be with some masculine ass [ __ ] who's
trying to run a relationship all the
time that's the bottom line on that
but getting back to this man question
lying to women guys is counterproductive
what do i mean by it's counterproductive
guys
if you're going to lie about anything
you want to lie about you
are dating women that you do have a
woman so let's hypothetically say you
meet a woman
you better off telling her that you do
have a woman then you don't
that that's you mo liable to [ __ ] her
that way the only one you won't [ __ ] is
the woman who's looking for a
relationship
well that's only going to be like maybe
30 or 40 percent that's hypothetical to
say 50 and 50.
all right so that's only going to be
what the other 50 percent of women
if you tell them that you ain't got
nobody
won't you and even some of those girls
that are looking for a relationship let
me tell y'all guys something
even the women who are looking for a
relationship
the fact that you married lets them know
that at least you are the settle down
type so some of those
might want to [ __ ] with you too because
a lot of guys are not even
even like i'm gonna tell y'all got some
guys who are successful
guys who have their [ __ ] together a lot
of these guys don't want to do nothing
but play around
i'm telling you that [ __ ] right now guys
a lot of guys who have their own crib a
nice crib
they body in shape they make good money
they dress nice
those guys don't want to do that but
[ __ ] as many [ __ ] as they can
so when a woman do meet a guy that has
his [ __ ] together
if he is in a relationship or even if he
is married
at least she knows he's open to the
opportunity of settling down
all right that's the thing with that
guys that's the thing with that so don't
never get that constructed that having a
woman or being in a relationship or
being married
takes you out of qualifying for anything
in a lot of the cases
it helps you all right that's why i
always tell you guys
even if you're not dating and tell a
woman you are dating people
you don't wanna listen if you're gonna
lie a lot of right way lying try to
raise your
smv i ain't they nobody i ain't had a
date in a long time
i just what day you're available i'm
available every day i'm feeling monday
tuesday wednesday thursday
i'm available lunch breakfast dinner i
got all day available
that's the worst thing you want to do
all right you want a woman
no no i think you have options all right
so guys stop thinking that [ __ ] okay i
do agree with what he said about being
like too available
like if a guy doesn't seem to have
anything going on
like he just see like
you kind of wonder i mean like in the
getting to know someone like
process if that makes sense like it's
the same thing with a girl if a girl
like
literally has no hobbies and only wants
to hang out with you all the time like
kind of like what's wrong in a
relationship and marriage is
disqualified it is gonna disqualify you
from some women who are looking for a
relationship because they're gonna
classify you as a cheat
and so that's fine you're gonna lose
those that's fine
but you have to tell the [ __ ] truth
first of all she's gonna figure it out
the first [ __ ] week
aight women are not [ __ ] stupid guys
yeah we'll we'll stalk
the [ __ ] out of you yeah when i was in a
relationship
and this one i didn't know no better and
i used to be trying to date
uh cheat at the beginning of the
relationship you know didn't know about
about
just tell the truth and [ __ ] if you
don't want to be in a relationship but
at one time i was in a relationship and
i was trying to cheat at the very
beginning
those girls would always be calling at
10 11 o'clock at night why the [ __ ] do
y'all think they did that
they did that because they know okay if
he ain't got no girlfriend he probably
can answer the phone
all right i could never answer the
[ __ ] phone so they gonna figure the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out anyway
so they have to be down with it guys all
right so they have to be down with the
plan
but guys stop thinking that women
having a girl at home lowers a woman's
attraction it's gonna
i had a girl back home this is years ago
like maybe 24 25
and there was a girl next door that i
wanted to [ __ ] and i was dating another
girl
and that girl wouldn't even give me the
time of day till her grandma told her oh
he got a pretty little girl come over
there
now all of a sudden she find me a
tractor that [ __ ] wouldn't even give me
the time of day
until her grandma told her and she told
me tell me something y'all heard about
your little pretty girlfriend you come
over here uh-huh my grandma told me
she ain't gonna give me the time of day
now she wanna [ __ ] me because her
grandma told her i had a little chick
coming over
y'all guys get what i'm saying so that's
the thing with that guys
is that that actually raises your smv so
if
i don't think so like
i forgot sorry guys my sister keeps
texting me um
like if a guy has a girlfriend my first
thought is
okay i mean now i'm in a relationship
but like when i wasn't
like my first thought would be like
no you know everything else stays the
same if you're in a relationship and you
just want to cheat i
i prefer you tell your woman you want an
open relationship
but if you know she gonna make your life
a living hell and you don't want to deal
with that [ __ ]
and you just want to do it with this you
go out and you why don't you find a
girlfriend that's into that stuff
women the same way and it should be
easier for you to
meet women unless you're in a bad
relationship
and you ain't having sex and [ __ ] like
that but a man who's in a relationship
always guys i got the most choosing
signals when i was in a relationship
all right you just care you can't fake
that energy
all right even me now dating women i
don't carry
myself with the same nonchalantly that i
did
when i had a piece of ass laying next to
me every night in the bed
it's a it's a it's a different type of
swagger
i always got my most choosing signals
when i was in a relationship especially
from co-workers all right and even if
they didn't know
but whenever i had a girlfriend a steady
girlfriend that's when i always got my
most choosing signals all right
even what are choosing signals me dating
chicks now
i could be dating seven women and i
still don't get as many choosing signals
as i did when i had a steady girlfriend
at home when i was in a relationship i
always got my most choosing signals
in a relationship okay is he gonna get
to the point
like at all okay just a swag and you
can't you can't duplicate it it's a look
all right and what i mean by that guys
is when you see
knit [ __ ] every [ __ ] night when you
go out into the world
your energy is different all right when
you date
you still go a day or two without seeing
some ass so you still gonna give off a
little energy a little thirsty energies
not maybe not that
bad but when you got [ __ ] land next to
you in a bed every night and you see it
every night when you out in the public
you don't you don't stare or look the
same because you see it every [ __ ]
night if i hope i'm making myself clear
i hope i'm making some sense
so you you you have the perfect energy
to get choosing signals
and a woman can smell it you just a
woman can have on some little shorts way
up here in a halter top on and a guy who
has [ __ ] land next to him in the bed
every night have a fine girl laying next
to him naked every night
he ain't gonna give off the same energy
as a guy who ain't ain't seen a woman
naked
i have no idea what he's talking about
get in a day or two and if you're a guy
who's just dating you still gonna go a
day or two
all right sometimes because that's
hypothetical say you gotta
how do you guys have this much like free
time
to just five girl rotation well that
still leave two nights
that you got so you still ain't gonna
see it the same way a guy who got
living and [ __ ] it's a different energy
so as america you should be getting the
most
choosing signals all right because you
just give off that vibe it's just the
vibe guys
so everything else holds true guys you
just have to tell
tell the women that you have a wife at
home and they either down with it or
they not
all right but that's the way that goes
guys all right
so there are girls
that like they don't know a guy at all
right so they just meet him at a random
place
and they're like they don't care and my
boy
champ had a good question too he said
can when a girl
run a background check on you
uh and she got high interest does that
lower
can that lower uh her interest hell
[ __ ] yeah but
not the way you guys might think uh
here's the thing guys
when a woman like you that's
hypothetically a woman with high
interest like you just
you do it for her theoretically your
finances
and your social status cannot lower her
attraction
because she already like you the only
thing that can lure her attraction if
she found out you have some ugly
girlfriends
so that's hypothetical say you at school
what
how does that matter and a girl running
a background checks you don't care
if which how much money you got or you
know if you got a lawyer
she already liked you you just but she
found out you had a 300 pound girlfriend
and now we got a problem now we got a
big [ __ ] problem
see that's the issue with that guys that
can hurt you now
with a girl that has low interest
your your friend your social circle and
your finances can help you
and let me give y'all an example so
let's hypothetically say
a girl go ask another girl oh you know
him
and she oh yeah girl he he the number
one salesman for mercedes-benz he's the
number one salesman in the county
oh yeah girl he sold more cars to
everybody
ah he tried to talk to me girl you need
to go get with him
see when a girl with low interest that
can help you but that don't really help
you with a girl who you just
do it for all right if you just do it
for a girl
and she just find you attracting you
just do it for i do agree
like if you find
like if i if i liked like even with um
like my boyfriend now when i met him
like i just i don't know i just
felt like we like clicked right away and
it wouldn't have even mattered like
anything else if that makes sense like i
don't know some people you just really
connect with
the only thing that in my experience
what i've seen in my life
is that if you [ __ ] some ugly [ __ ] or
some
no no i would just say if you find them
being like
dishonest like that's really
unattractive
women that was not on her caliber that
will lower her attraction and she'll
bring it to you too
all right she'll bring it to you another
thing that allure her attraction is
is she found out you try to talk to
everybody oh girl yeah i talked to my
friend he tried to talk to me
yes oh my gosh yes
yes that's true like if you try to just
talk to everybody like you just out just
randomly talking to everybody
and especially if they turned you down
so that's how
you try to talk to her friend this girl
that girl and they all turned you down
and now i'm talking to you
i'm getting leftovers they didn't even
want you now i got you
so in that situation guys it can hurt
you if a girl found out that you got
rejected
that's the problem at like a small
school that like i went to you find out
everything
a lot and if you had an ugly girlfriend
so y'all guys
guys this is more reason what i said
wait on choosing signals because if it
comes around
that if you got all these rejections and
i've had this happen to
me before i had a girl come confront me
about this before and said you tried to
she had two of her friends knew who i
was
and both of them had rejected me this
years ago like years ago
because you know this one when i went on
my purpose and weighed no choosing
signals i would just
you know talk to girls and i had no fear
of rejection all right that's this
before i got that swag so i would just
talk to girls i wasn't
afraid of rejection two girls tell me
i'm killing anybody maybe i'm not that
tight
maybe they had their peers on that day i
don't give a [ __ ] and i really didn't
give a [ __ ]
but she asked her friends yeah she
thinking like she got her prize and
oh i got me and she going to talk to her
friends and found out they rejected me
all right you don't think he'll attract
well that's that's true because then you
don't feel like you're special
if he's literally like copying and
pasting the same dm
action drop now we still [ __ ] around
but her attraction dropped
all right because they didn't even want
you and now i'm with you
is he even gonna get to the how to cheat
video i i don't think he did
all right so guys you have to be
cognizant that's another thing choosing
signals you don't want
girls to just see everybody that
rejected you and girls
ask this [ __ ] guys girls gonna ask their
friend girl you know him because
the reason they do that guys the reason
they run a background check
is because they don't want to talk to a
guy that they friend the [ __ ]
or some [ __ ] like that like with us we
don't care i don't care if you [ __ ] my
best friend
but god forbid if a girl but you would
if you were dating her
you don't care for like a girl you're
hooking up with i bet he would if he was
dating
[ __ ] a guy that her best friend so they
always go ask all their friends you know
him you know him you know him
oh yeah girl he tried to talk to me last
year i did turn off
guys dead turn off it won't turn off all
the times of her attraction high enough
but it will lower her attraction all
right so that's the thing so maybe she
saw you as a 10 maybe that bring it down
to a nine or something like that
but it's no big deal you can still only
on all the time it really hurt you is
like say you was like a
eight or seven or something like that
and it can hurt you then
but she got super high attraction it
can't lower it that much
but it does hurt all right as in with
the low interest girl
if a girl go find out you [ __ ] how the
chicks
i you guys i've had girls that rejected
me
then did a background check and all of a
sudden they were sending choosing
signals all right
probably because they found i have never
looked at
okay i have never looked at someone's
that like dating history that i was like
talking to
like once i started like dating somebody
then i would look
but like i've never done that like
looked before i even talked to them
found out something probably found out i
i've dealt with this girl whatever the
case may be i don't know what the [ __ ]
they found out maybe they found out i
was good in bed i don't [ __ ] know
they heard something
and next time i was with uh around them
they sent in choosing signals all right
but i just want y'all guys to be
cognizant of that that yeah if you go
and you [ __ ] with uh
girls who got high interest and they run
every girl runs a background check guys
before she takes you on
as somebody she's gonna date she gonna
ask her friends cause she don't wanna
[ __ ] somebody to her friends before so
she's gonna ask
and her friends find out that uh one of
her friends know you had an ugly
girlfriend
last year or you got rejected by five of
her friends that will lower her
attraction
no doubt a [ __ ] bout it guy the
rejection
for fabio friends i agree with i feel
like he did not even talk about
how did she other than to say to do it
honestly
cool which i agree with but like
gosh i like i don't like the way that
sounds like the way he talks
and stuff that did not
made me feel some type of way but
anyways let me know in the comments
if like what you agree with what you
disagree with
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe
bye